porque es tan especial esta jornada de
hoy 40 días después de la muerte de
maxamney Hola buenas tardes
la ante en la tradición Chita porque
representa un momento en el cual se
acaba el luto familiar Entonces
se es importante volver a visitar al
difunto y estar a su estar cerca es lo
que han hecho todos estos miles de
iraníes que están acercado al cementerio
encurtistán a pesar de que la policía ha
intentado cerrar las calles Cómo se
explique que la muerte de maxam inicia
ya convertido en esta movilización
contra el gobierno iraní las protestas
que vemos tienen un nivel nacional y
además no se detienen
en efecto porque se junta No solamente
la rabia o la ira por la muerte de una
inocente por cumplir los preceptos de la
República islámica porque llevaba el
pañuelo pero no también como ellos
querían sino porque se ha juntado con un
contexto de descontento por una
corrupción galopante por una
incompetencia económica por una
represión que todo junto Lleva más de 40
años sometiendo a la población no
solamente a las mujeres iraníes sino a
toda la población iraní qué antecedentes
tenemos en este país en Irán de unas
movilizaciones de este tipo
desde el 1999 que hubo unas primeras
movilizaciones de estudiantiles las más
importantes se pueden reflejar en el
2009 a raíz de las elecciones
presidenciales en las cuales hubo un
gran descontento porque se creyó que
había habido fraude electoral la
contienda era entre musabi reformista
del régimen y a manivellat que era de
Lala dura del
régimen la población sobre todo la gente
más de acuerdo con los reformistas
denunciaron que podía haber vivido un
fraude y se unieron en un movimiento que
se llamó movimiento verde actualmente
musabi sigue en arresto domiciliario y
ese movimiento se acabó en el día en el
cual amadís ya fue declarado proclamado
presidente